Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Bethenny Frankel,
founder of the game‐changing
mega‐brand Skinnygirl
joins the Tank.
I created a cocktail.
Some of the best ideas
are the simplest.
Lace Your Face.
I don't know
if it's attractive.
I'm a one‐man show.
This is the guy
which takes you to the top.
Palmini punches calories
in the face.
Whoa!     Whoa!
Whoa!                      Whoa!
Who wants to thrive with us?
No!
You're all over
the place.
I promise
it's gonna be worth it.
The B. S. meters are
[Imitates beeping]
What were your sales?
$1.3 million.
What?
The sharks
are circling.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a business
hoping to become
a lifestyle brand.
♪♪
[ Argentinean accent ]
Hello, Sharks.
How are you?
My name is Uki Deane.
I am from the beautiful city
of Buenos Aires, Argentina,
and I am seeking
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for a 20% stake
in my company.
Sharks, two years ago,
I was sitting
in my corporate‐finance job just
wishing I could be at the beach.
So, you know what I did?
I looked at my boss
straight into the eyes,
I gathered all the courage
I had, and I said,
"I quit, goodbye, ciao!"
[ Laughter ]
I then put
all of my life savings
into starting a fantastic line
of swimwear
I proudly call...
Bermies.
Bermies are not only
extremely fashionable,
but they're also
very affordable.
So now, thanks to Bermies,
you can chill at the beach
and look good and feel fantastic
while sipping that piña colada.
Sharks, the number‐one feedback
I get from all of my customers
is that Bermies ‐‐
the most comfortable swim trunks
they have ever worn.
Because unlike
those other brands,
Bermies made from
premium‐quality fabrics,
making them stretchy,
breathable,
but more importantly,
super fast‐drying.
So, Sharks, what do you say?
Jump on the Bermies adventure
with me,
and let's sail away
to our next destination.
[ Chuckles ]
Greiner: Good job.
Can we see them?
I have some samples for you.
I love his accent.
First one's for you.
Thank you.
Cuban:
One for him...
Second one for you.
Greiner:
Thank you.
Cuban:
Thank you, Uki.
Herjavec: Oh, I like
the pink ones, Lori.
You want the pink, Robert?
I'll trade with you.
Oh, I like
the green, too.
Oh, wow.
I chose them specifically
all for you.
Deane: I want you first
to feel that quality, okay?
Herjavec: Feeling.
Feeling that quality.
Bathing suits like that,
you have not seen before.
Greiner:
We haven't?
The quality
is very different.
Herjavec: What ‐‐ What's
different with the material?
The difference is,
most bathing suits
are made out of 100% polyester,
and the reason for that is
because it's a cheap material.
It dries fast,
people are used to it,
and they think
that men just buy.
They're not like women,
which go and touch and feel.
But, Uki, those are only
the cheap ones.
The more
expensive ones...
The more expensive ones ‐‐
for example, Vilebrequin...
Frankel:
Vilebrequin, yeah.
All right, Vilebrequin sells
between $200, $300.
Oh, wow.
What do these
sell for?
These sell for $40.99 retail.
I'm at that 50% benchmark,
right below them,
so you can get people
who have disposable income
and can buy them.
These types of swim trunks
you won't find at this price
point anywhere in the market.
How much does it cost
to have them made?
Approximately $9.80.
That's great.
Yeah.
They should be
about $6.50, though.
It can be, 100%, at $6.50.
These type of swim trunks you
won't find at this price point
anywhere in the market ‐‐
a bathing suit which has cool,
funky patterns like this
and also offers that quality,
you won't find for $40.99.
Uki, Uki, a turtle is not
cool or funky, right?
Greiner:
And you said ‐‐
They're always
on swimsuits.
John: Uki, I've been doing this
for 25 years.
Yes, sir.
[ Chuckles ]
This stuff
is everywhere.
I ‐‐
I promise you
at the same price...
Yes.
...'cause I made it.
Okay.
No problem.
When I started FUBU,
I didn't put three sleeves
on a shirt.
Shirts have been
existing everywhere, too.
Doesn't mean that
this is not a great business.
What you're doing,
it is good.
Very good quality.
So now, let's get into
the business stuff.
The reason you want to buy
these bathing suits
and invest in me...
Yeah.
...is because of this guy.
There you go.
Frankel: Yes!
Deane: This is the guy
which takes you to the top.
How old are you?
Do you mind if I ask?
I'm 27 years old.
27 years old.
Good for you.
All right.
Do you have any sales?
Okay.
The first official year is 2016.
Okay.                      Okay.
In 2016,
I made $271,000 in sales.
Good for you.
Greiner: Wow.
Okay.
And those stores are online
or combination?
Deane: Okay, so,
I've done trade shows.
I started off
taking pictures of Bermuda.
I do everything.
I'm a one‐man show.
I started doing the pictures,
I do the marketing,
I designed
all of these bathing suits.
I do absolutely everything,
okay? I'm a hustler.
Um, and when I started...
I love him.
...taking pictures of friends...
I love you.
...in Bermuda ‐‐
If you had a 3 in front
of your age, we'd be married.
[ Laughter ]
So when I started taking
pictures of people in Bermuda,
started talking
to their friends...
Man:
Just start swimming?
...and I started building up
Instagram.
I don't even know
what you're talking about!
[ Laughing ]
He's just talking.
It's amazing.
I'm sorry.
Keep on going.
I'll follow you, Uki.
Then I said,
"Hm, how do I get more people?"
So I said Kickstarter.
I did a Kickstarter...
Ahh.
...I asked for $10,000,
I got $30,000. Okay.
On these?
That was in 2016?
Do you own ‐‐
This was 2016.
Okay.
What were your sales
so far this year?
This year, as of September,
I am at $300,000 in sales.
Good for you.
Good.
Greiner: Wow.
Deane: And I'm estimating
an increase of 20%.
Do you
own the company alone?
Uki Deane, 100%.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And where
did you get the money?
Okay, so,
the money is ‐‐
I basically put in $100,000
into the business.
You did,
of your own money.
Cuban:
You started off ‐‐
Okay, I‐I will get there.
[ Laughter ]
So, I started ‐‐
I started ‐‐
It wasn't
your own money.
It is, it is!
Listen, listen, listen.
Herjavec: Lori,
we're gonna get there!
Give him some time.
One second.
I started off with $25,000
of my own money,
then I started having
cash‐flow issues
because I was doing trade shows.
I asked my family,
they gave me $25,000 more.
Then I started having
more orders,
and this is just droving me ‐‐
driving me crazy, and I said...
Why was that
driving you crazy?
Cuban: Because he doesn't have
the cash to make them.
Because I have no money to put
into manufacturing orders...
Oh, to manufacture, got it,
got it, got it, got it.
...and they want to pay
once they get the delivery...
I have been there.
So, I said I had to find a way,
and my grandparents
had given me some stocks.
And I said,
"Whatever, I'll sell it."
I sold those stocks
and I got $50,000 more
and here I am
seeking more money.
Wow.
So how big
is your online presence?
Wholesale, 2 retailers
is about 80% of my business.
The online is only 20%.
We have a product
called Sand Cloud.
It's three guys
from San Diego...
I've cooperated
with sometimes.
...and they ran into
cash‐flow problems, right?
Yep.
So they couldn't
build inventory,
they couldn't do wholesale
like you,
so they use Instagram.
Correct.
People take their picture,
and they're killing it.
Exactly what I'm ‐‐
$7 million this year.
I have people tagging me...
But that's only
20% of your business.
That is correct.
Okay.
And that is what I want to grow,
because how do you grow
that much?
You got to push marketing.
How many
social networking followers?
Yeah, how many?
How many, Uki?
Right now, 25,000.
Frankel: Okay.
It's okay.
That's not bad.
No, it's okay.
It's not huge.
Is that you?
So, here's the story
on this.
I said,
"What's the cheapest place
I can go to try and get
more pictures?"
So I jumped on a plane,
I flew to southeast Asia,
I walked and approached
random people at the beach
and I said, "Hello."
Okay,
hold on.
But that's not Bermuda.
Cheapest, closest place
is southeast Asia?
No, cheap ‐‐
in terms of cheapness
and, like, finding people
who are vacationing
and are willing
to take their pictures, 100%.
It says "Bermies."
There's no way that
the cheapest way to get a guy ‐‐
a picture of a guy with
a man bun and a soccer ball...
[ Laughter ]
...is to go
to southeast Asia,
which brings up
the question
of whether or not you're able
to manage cash.
Deane:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
His point is just you
could've gone to Venice Beach.
You could've gone
to South Beach.
Good point.
I'm...
Like, you could've gone
anywhere a little bit closer,
a little
less expensive.
Photographers cost
about $5,000, okay?
You have to then
hire the models. Yes ‐‐
No!
All these Inst‐‐
All these millennials.
Don't you have a phone
with a camera?
I could've done it in Miami,
but I wanted
to build a lifestyle.
I wanted to build
the concept of my brand.
Frankel: But you need
to build up.
I wanted to show ‐‐
You're not ‐‐ You can't make
a brand out of a lifestyle.
If I have a beach ‐‐
in Venice Beach ‐‐
You cannot run around
taking pictures
and, you know,
wearing shorts and that's ‐‐
No,
let me finish.
I was you.
I had a healthy
baked‐goods company
called Bethenny Bakes ‐‐
wheat‐, egg‐, and dairy‐free ‐‐
and I was taking money
and spending it as I went.
It was like walking into a mall
without a plan
and just being, like,
"Oh, I like that, I like that,"
and then coming home and
being like, "Wait, I have
nothing to show for this."
So here you are.
You're a little manic,
which I get, 'cause I am, too.
I was you.
You're all over
the place.
If you're
getting money here,
you have to have a plan
for the money,
not, "I'm going here,
I'm going there, I'm doing this,
I'm doing that,
the Bermuda shorts"...
It's a lifestyle.
...but they're not ‐‐
You can't just say words
like "lifestyle,"
which everybody says
"lifestyle brand,"
and it means nothing.
You have to create a brand
with a plan.
What's the plan
right now?
What comes next?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they want to hear
a solid business plan from Uki
on how he's going to grow
his men's swim‐short company,
Bermies.
Everybody says
"lifestyle brand,"
and it means nothing.
You have to create a brand
with a plan.
What's the plan
right now?
Cuban:
What comes next?
The plan right now
is to build a team, okay?
I need to build a team to be
able to get to the next stage.
I can't handle everything
right now.
Cuban: Uki, I think the future
of selling swimwear
and products like this
is online.
And that's where I'm going.
Cuban:
But that's not where you're at,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Man: You remind me, honestly,
of a young Robert.
You do.
Um, but you're everywhere,
right, and that's what ‐‐
Herjavec: You mean
because of the body?
[ Greiner laughs ]
John:
The enthusiasm.
A lot of energy,
but I wish you luck. I'm out.
Thank you.
Uki, listen,
your energy is fabulous.
Thank you.
Your passion
is fabulous,
and I know
that it'll go far for you.
You could probably
sell mud,
and that's what
they said about me.
The problem for me
about this is,
is I think you're in
a super crowded space.
♪♪
I'm sorry, I'm out,
but I think you'll go far.
Thank you very much.
I know
I talked a little bit about
all these things that I've done,
but I'm trying to learn.
If I'd just been sitting down
in my little office saying,
"Oh, no, southeast Asia's
too far away, too much money,"
I wouldn't have gone, I wouldn't
have had the lifestyle.
If I would have said, like,
"Ooh, no,
there's 100,000 different brands
of swim trunks" ‐‐
What lifestyle?!
What are you
talking about?
Exactly, what lifestyle?
If there's, like, 100 ‐‐
There's too much competition,
it's scary.
Uki, I...
Yeah.
I...
I love the energy...
[ Laughter ]
...I love the passion.
I'm so tired of him.
And I love the fun.
But at
a certain point...
Yeah.
...I kind of
want to put the fun aside
and I want to talk about
real business stuff.
And through
your entire presentation,
I was waiting
for that.
You're all over the map,
my friend.
I cannot follow
the bouncing ball.
I was hoping it was gonna land
in an online strategy...
But that's ‐‐
...where you're sending
to millennials
and people
are tagging you...
But that is ‐‐
...and they're
your biggest sales force.
I'm already doing that,
and I don't have the funds to
invest into marketing right now,
which is why I'm searching
part of the money to do that.
That's what you're ‐‐
Frankel: That will end up
down the toilet
if you don't have
your whole business lined up.
Yeah, th‐‐
you're missing the point.
Your cost of marketing
in that area is the lowest part.
You could've built a brand
around that.
I could see so many connections
with my other products
that are in the same industry,
but you scare me.
You're ‐‐ You're too much fun
and you're too scattered.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for the honesty.
So, there's two
different lengths ‐‐
Everybody has two lengths!
They don't.
They really don't.
What are you ‐‐
What are you
talking about?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Uki, why are you
arguing with him
when you have
one Sharkette left?
You should be asking her
what she wants to know
in case
she might want to invest.
I'm sorry. Bethenny,
is there anything else
you would like to know?
[ Laughs ]
No.
The ‐‐ The thing is ‐‐
The thing is...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...that
I don't know how ‐‐
you guys
were probably all geniuses
when you were young and ‐‐ and
were very successful young.
No.
I didn't ‐‐
I was not successful
until I was 37 years old.
I was ‐‐ I was broke,
living in a studio apartment,
and I had
all these ideas.
I was always the one hustling
with the ideas.
And you're not
supposed to know everything,
and you are
supposed to be scattered
because you're
27 years old.
And the one thing
I will say
is I created a cocktail
that was very basic,
but it was
a problem‐solver.
Some of the best ideas
are the simplest.
You're very complicated.
This is like
other things.
It's very manic
and ADD
and you are going to
hit it out of the park
and you're going to
show all of us,
but for now,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you very much, guys,
for your time.
Cuban:
Congrats, Uki.
Good luck, Uki.
But, gentlemen, seriously,
when you try them on
and you see
how comfortable they are...
Cuban:
We'll buy 10 more.
Never stop selling.
Yes. Yeah.
Ask the production.
I love that.
Thank you very much,
guys.
Cuban:
Congrats, Uki.
Bye.
He was great.
Good luck.
Deane: I think they made
a very big mistake.
I have given everything I have,
I quit my job,
I put all of my life savings,
and I am committed.
And when somebody is committed
and driven
and has an objective
to reach that goal,
they won't stop.
So try and stop me.
The Sharks clearly didn't.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator:
This season, we welcomed
inspirational new Sharks
to the tank.
That's the type of work
we need from you
in the classroom when your
teachers are talking to you.
What I tell
the next generation is,
"You don't have to hit
home runs.
You can also chase your dreams
through education."
Blakely:
I'm a big believer that the
world would be a better place
if women were elevated
on the planet
and given the chance
to fulfill their dreams.
Frankel: I want women to know
it is the most empowering thing
to make your own money
and execute your own ideas.
Oza:
It's known as the American dream
because people
can start with nothing,
have a great idea, and build it
into something special.
Branson: I think "Shark Tank"
influences a lot of young people
to actually
become entrepreneurs,
and they will become the
Richard Branson of the future
because of watching
"Shark Tank."
Narrator: We saw
astronomical successes.
Krause: We only had about
$100,000 in retail sales,
and now we've broken
$141 million.
Brown:
Within five minutes of airing,
I had sold out
of all of my inventory.
Just three months later,
we just passed the $50 million
in retail sales mark.
Taranto:
Sales were $350,000.
This year, we'll do
over $100 million in sales.
Samtani:
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we did $87,000 in sales.
2 1/2 years later, we're now
at $7 million in sales.
Mills: So much has happened
since making the deal with
Kevin four months ago.
We're now in 81 cities
and 15 states.
Siminoff:
I think Ring is proof
that entrepreneurship is still
alive and well in America.
It's now been four years
since "Shark Tank,"
and the business is now valued
at $1 billion.
Narrator: And we watched
"Shark Tank" businesses
continue to change the world.
Shresta: I think
in times like this,
giving people a form of
portable power gives them hope,
and we're just glad that
our light and our phone chargers
are there to help.
Look at all this.
This is insane.
Herjavec:
We're getting to a point
that there'll be more plastic
in the ocean
than there will be fish,
and that's sad.
But it's also great that we can
help in some small way.
Our families
are loving it.
Cuban:
I'm a Shark, but I'm also a dad.
But now with Brightwheel,
we can impact
the early education of millions
of children across this country.
That's incredible,
and, you know, that's the beauty
of "Shark Tank."
Corcoran: When you're a Shark,
it's great to make money,
but more important,
you can invest in businesses
you actually believe in.
We're not just
making dreams come true,
we're making a difference
in people's lives.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
who believe they have a better
version of a hot beauty trend.
♪♪
Hi,
I'm Anita Sun Eisenberg.
And I'm
Mariella Scott.
We're from
Los Angeles, California,
and we're Dermovia...
Lace Your Face.
[ Laughter ]
We're seeking $350,000
for 10% equity
in our compan‐‐
in our company.
Yeah, I‐I stutter
on that one, too.
Masking has been a go‐to
skincare treatment for ages.
Masks help
with hydration.
They clear your pores.
They even make all your other
beauty products work better.
But we've definitely
come a long way
since the green,
goopy, messy masks...
[ Laughter ]
...our moms used to use,
and thank goodness,
because I still have nightmares.
[ Chuckles ]
Sheet masks are the latest
development and beauty craze.
They've streamlined
the process,
but still face
their own set of challenges.
Sheet masks
are slippery and slimy,
and without a way
of securing it,
you have to stay
completely still
for the entire length
of the treatment
to prevent the mask
from slipping off your face
and the ingredients
from getting into your eyes.
That can take
up to an hour.
Who has time
for that?
[ Chuckles ]
That's where we come in.
We're transforming
the mask industry with...
Are you ready
for it?
Cuban: Ta‐da.
Greiner: Yeah, we're ready.
Lace Your Face,
an innovative design
that allows you to multitask
while you mask.
Lace Your Face is made of
a cotton‐stretch fabric
saturated in serum.
Wow.
It fastens to your face
with our patented ear hook.
[ Squealing ]
[ Laughs ]
I'll give you
all my money!
Looks like Halloween.
Eisenberg: The straps
not only secure the mask,
but it also offers
gentle compression,
which activates the body's
natural reparative response
and allows the product
to work better and faster.
Did they tell you this was
going to be on national TV
and repeat
20 times a day?
Yes.
Yes, and we wanted
to show you.
We're on a mission to give you
the best skin you deserve...
Wow.
...without sacrificing
your precious time.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to...
[ Laughter ]
...mask and multitask
with Lace Your Face?
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Wow, sure.
Can we see samples?
Scott:
Yes, of course.
Are they reusable,
or is this disposable?
Each mask has enough serum
that you can use it twice.
Oh, but it's not ‐‐
right.
So two treatments.
It's a lacy,
stretchy fabric...
Yes.
Cuban: It's like putting
underwear on your face.
...so you're actually
taking your serum
and infusing it
all over this.
It's ‐‐ These are in the pouches
saturated in serum.
Yeah.
I don't know
if it's attractive.
Oh, it's sexy.
Really?
I have a question,
'cause I use these.
I use ‐‐
Hi, there, pretty.
You look handsome.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want
any of the small bills.
[ Laughter ]
No small bills.
I am ‐‐ I use these,
and I know ‐‐
I used one on the
plane. I often ‐‐ People
think I'm crazy...
You put this
on the plane?
Greiner:
You used this?
I bring it ‐‐
How do you
not scare people?
I do, but I don't care.
It's the plane. It's dark.
In Asia,
women mask every day.
I do the one
that the woman had on.
It's just
a pain in the ass.
Bethenny, would you wear that
on the plane?
I'd wear that to an event.
I mean, that looks beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you!
What does it cost you to put
together one of your packages?
Well, how to do sell,
first of all?
Yes, I didn't hear
the price before.
Scott: We sell
in a four‐pack box for $55
and single masks
for $15 retail.
$55?
Frankel:
Oh, $55 for four.
Okay,
that's a lot.
Okay, so,
$55 for four...
Wait, is that with
the four packages, too?
Eisenberg: Yes.
So, our margins right now
are 80%.
Wow.
Um, so ‐‐ so...
So what's it cost you
to make?
So what's it cost?
$3 for one pouch.
Our sales
are $1.3 million.
Over what period
of time?
Wow.
Our ‐‐ I'm sorry?
Over what
period of time?
So, we started late 2015,
and we sold $150,000.
Our second year, 2016,
we did $450,000,
and this year,
we're tracking $750,000.
Wow.
Cuban:
Good for you.
Where are you selling?
Scott: We are in
major department stores ‐‐
Nordstrom, Barneys...
Greiner: You are?
...and we're sold online.
Yes.
So you've really got
good distribution.
For me, the revolutionary
difference is, it stays on.
Yes.
Frankel: Very.
And I totally see
the convenience to that.
Do you have
a patent on this?
We have a patent
on this mask.
We actually have ‐‐
You do.
Utility patent?
The technology.
So, we have two pending
utility patents on file,
and we have
an issued design patent.
With so much
in the margin, right,
so much
of the margin ‐‐
which is great, first of all,
from an investor standpoint ‐‐
but why is it
so much?
I'm a
medical aesthetician.
We formulated a wide variety
of masks and treatment
to mimic the treatment that
they could get in the clinic
at home.
Is that why there's
a premium cost, because...
Right, because this undergoes
a medical‐grade sterilization.
This is beautiful packaging,
but it doesn't scream $55.
You could get a facial
for not much more,
and a facial
is more effective.
Mm.
So that's a lot.
$55 is my problem right now.
So ‐‐ So, the thing with the
price point is that right now,
we are producing
in lower volume,
and on top of that,
the ingredients are all
naturally derived actives.
Ladies, this industry
has the highest margins
of almost
any other industry.
Right.
Massive margins,
I've learned,
invite
massive competition...
Right.
...that really doesn't want you
to be successful.
I see a lot of challenge
in the future.
So,
that's why...
It's not for me.
...we applied
for the patents.
It's not for me.
And you're scaring me.
I'm out.
[ Chuckles ]
I'll simplify it, guys.
I love the mask, I'll wear it
every day, but I'm out.
♪♪
So, I‐I like this
because I am this person,
and every time I post
a picture of myself
in one of these crazy masks,
everyone says,
"What mask do you use?
What brand is that?"
I would have conditions ‐‐
the price
would have to come down.
You'd have to get each one
under $10 a piece,
so, like, $39 for 4.
That would have to happen.
$55 is way too much
for this product.
And the fun part
is, uh, 30%.
$350,000 for 30%.
I'm going back
to a question.
So, why are
these formulas great?
So ‐‐ You have an offer
right here.
Right.
Bethenny.
They look ‐‐
They look so excited.
What, you want to go
take a nap?
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Huh?
No,
we're just...
Want to moisturize
over it?
Sorry!
Eisenberg:
We were just process‐‐
No, we were processing it.
Oh, my God, my bad.
Sorry.
Cuban: Wow.
I wanted
to explain ‐‐
I wanted to explain more about
the price point of the mask.
Take it off, just so people
can see your beautiful faces.
Mariella and Anita,
thank you for educating, uh, me
on what
women go through,
but I don't know
anything about this,
uh, this world,
so I'm no help. I'm out.
♪♪
I know that you have
a technician background,
an aesthetic background.
I'm not sure
why these are better
than anything else
out there.
I don't know
if people would buy in at $55
for your formulas
without you becoming
a bigger‐known brand.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
Wow.
So now you're back
to the original offer.
Cuban:
Now you have one offer.
So we had to go through all that
to get back to here.
Guys,
you can counteroffer.
We'd like to ‐‐
Frankel: How much inventory
do you have?
Sorry, just one question.
How much inventory do
you have right now?
So, currently,
we have 50,000 units on hand.
Wow.
We have
two pending orders,
totaling
about 1 million units.
♪♪
What?
Right now?
Wow.
And you just now ‐‐ Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
[ Laughter, chatter ]
Wait.
So we really need ‐‐
So we really need the capital...
Frankel: Got it.
...to fulfill
the order.
So, okay, you have an offer.
What do you want to do?
Wait, who are you selling
a million units to?
Wait ‐‐
a million units to...?
Oh, look at them
all coming.
Why did you not think
to bring that up?
The sharks are circling.
The bait is in the water.
It's why they call it
"Shark Tank," Bethenny.
We have a hard order.
You do?
For a million units?
And who's it for?
It's for
a subscription box.
I'm counting
from 10 to 1.
Oh, you mean somebody who sends
beauty boxes to your home?
10...9...
Ladies,
she's counting down.
8...7...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
She's counting down the offer.
Where can we buy...
6...5...
Eisenberg: Bethenny, would you
be able to take ‐‐
We can't give away
that much equity.
Would you be able to take,
um, $350,000 for 15%?
♪♪
No.
I'll do it.
♪♪
Cuban: Done.
John:
Yes or no?
Okay.
Herjavec: What?!
[ Laughter ]
They're so excited!
Oh, my God,
they're so excited.
They're in shock.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: 15%?
Eisenberg:
Oh, my God!
It happens that quick.
Thanks, Lori.
All right,
I'll do it for 14%!
Thank you so much.
Greiner: You have
a million‐unit order?
Thank you, Bethenny.
I'mma send you a fruit basket
and some wine.
Lori was who
we wanted to begin with,
and we couldn't
be happier.
Lori was, like ‐‐
she's just sneaky,
and she just came right in
and swooped that deal up.
Think how good you'll be
at Halloween.
[ Laughs ]
That's what
I want to use it for.
Well ‐‐
Lori, just send me bunch
of free product when you ‐‐
I've never seen Lori become
a bottom‐feeder like that.
I'm taking
that whole display.
Lori was like a buzzard
on a gut wagon.
[ Laughs ]
She was like a hyena
on a wounded animal!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a healthier version
of a favorite guilty pleasure.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Alfonso Tejada.
I was born in Bolivia,
live in Miami, Florida,
and I'm here today
to gain $300,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company, O. A. Foods.
We are the creators
of the greatest game changer
in the history of pasta.
I think we can all agree
that pasta's
a worldwide food favorite.
But no matter how much
people love to eat pasta,
they try to stay away from it.
Yeah, because they know
it's bad for you.
It hangs out
with a pretty rough crowd.
[ Laughs ]
Bad dudes like calories,
carbs, sugar, and gluten.
Boo.
I think it's time we say "adios"
to pasta and hello to Palmini!
♪♪
Cuban: Oh!
[ Applause ]
[ Chatter ]
Frankel: Linguini.
Molto bene.
John:
How you been?
See, Palmini not only
looks like pasta,
but it can also
taste like pasta.
I love it.
And it doesn't associate with
any of these offenders.
[ Laughs ]
Actually, Palmini punches
calories in the face...
Whoa!     Whoa!
Whoa!                      Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
...kicks carbs in the stomach...
Herjavec: Yeah!
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
...practices muay thai
with sugar...
Greiner: Oh.
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
[ Laughs ]
...and says farewell to gluten.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
No!
You're such a beast,
Palmini!
Wow.
Palmini contains
only 15 calories,
3 grams of carbs, has no sugar,
and is gluten‐free...
[ Laughs ]
...but most importantly,
tastes so good.
Frankel: Wow.
Palmini is magical because
it's made out of hearts of palm,
which means it's 100% natural,
high in fiber,
and you can enjoy it
without having to worry about
adding any chemicals or
weird ingredients to your diet.
Not only is Palmini
better than pasta,
it's also easier to make
because it's already cooked.
All you need to do
is open, rinse,
add your choice of sauce...
Oh.
...heat, and enjoy a healthy
and delicious
low‐carb, low‐calorie meal
in a matter of minutes.
Regular noodles?
[ Scoffs ]
They're dead.
They passed away.
But Palmini?
Palmini's here to stay.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, who's ready
to try some Palmini?
All of us.
Let's try it.
John: Yeah.
Great presentation.
Frankel: Yes.
Very good presentation.
We needed that.
I'm dying to try it.
Did you bring
your vacuum cleaner?
[ Laughter ]
Feed me.
Tejada:
Yeah, we're gonna feed you
with three different sets
of Palmini,
that way you can try it
with different sauces...
Grazie!
...and different flavors.
Frankel: Amazing.
What are we eating here?
Okay,
the first one is a salad.
With shrimp?
Salad.
Yeah, with shrimp.
It's a little bit spicy.
A whole plate of this
would have 200 calories.
♪♪
Don't like that one.
The second one
is Parmesan garlic Alfredo,
and the third one
is just regular spaghetti...
Oh!
...with marinara and meatballs.
It's really good,
but I will say,
I love hearts of palm.
Same.
See, I thought
you were taking hearts of palm
and powdering it
and then making it
into a type of noodle.
But this is actually
the hearts of palm.
It's, like,
cut like a noodle, right?
Herjavec:
It's a vegetable.
Yeah, exactly.
It's really hard to do.
Mmm.
So it took us two years
to be able to develop this,
and right now,
it's patent‐pending
because the machine
literally took two years...
But, Alfonso,
it doesn't taste like pasta.
Um...
It doesn't
taste like pasta, no.
Some people ‐‐ Some people
think that it tastes...
I love it.
Yeah,
it's close enough to pasta.
Cuban: It's not bad, right?
It's not bad.
I feel a little disappointed.
I love pasta.
Frankel: No.
Zucchini noodles.
I love pasta, too,
but sometimes after I finish
eating pasta, I feel bloated,
and this,
you can eat as much as you want
and it's 90% water,
so...
But you could open a can
of hearts of palm
and eat
as much as you want
or spiralize zucchini
or cauliflower rice.
But I think we all thought
you were doing, like,
quinoa pasta...
Yeah.
...or spinach pasta.
This is just
a different‐shaped vegetable.
But the thing is,
you know,
you have
a cool product here because ‐‐
Yeah.
But it's a vegetable.
Well, what's wrong
with that? Because ‐‐
It is a vegetable.
I don't know
what's wrong with that, either.
Because the wave
of the ‐‐
No, look,
there's a lot of good reasons
to eat this
instead of pasta.
Right.
What's your background?
How do you know
food service?
So, I went to business school,
graduated summa cum laude
from the University of Florida,
then I moved to Bolivia to work
in my family's business.
We sell some agricultural
machinery in Bolivia.
While I was there,
I noticed that I had
really good access to quinoa.
Back then, in 2009,
nobody knew what quinoa was.
So I thought
it would be a good idea
to start importing quinoa
to the States,
because I knew
it was gonna explode.
And I'm offering you the both ‐‐
the quinoa business and...
Oh, well,
how big is the quinoa business?
Oh, great answer.
This year,
we've sold so far $400,000.
Of quinoa?
Good for you.
Of the quinoa,
yeah.
Okay.
Then we started ‐‐
Okay, Alfonso,
how big is the Palmini business?
Okay, so, the Palmini ‐‐
I got my container
three months ago.
It's sold about 2,000 units
and I ran out of stock.
So,
what's the dollar amount?
$50,000 in Palmini
in these three months.
So,
how much is this?
This is
what you're selling today.
So, that's right now
$9.99 on Amazon,
and it's way too expensive.
This is effectively
hearts of palm
shredded in
a different way.
There's no other
innovation here
except for
the processing machinery.
So what's to stop Del Monte
or any big company
from just
making that machine
and processing hearts of palm
in this way?
Okay, first of all, it took us
two years to make the machine.
But they have
billions of dollars.
It's patent‐pending.
What's the patent on?
The process machine.
And we ‐‐
On the machine to be able
to cut the hearts of palm
in the shape of linguine.
But that has happened
with everything.
The big guys
come in,
and then they can cut and ship
any shape they want.
Right.
I eat and use hearts of palm
fairly regularly.
They're very difficult
to deal with.
Whatever your process was,
it has to be really good,
because these are all
very uniform.
Yes.
How can you prevent the big guys
from doing this, though?
How can you prevent big
supermarkets just selling this?
Because I'm gonna get
one of you Sharks.
Well, you went
with the elephant.
Oh, that's the plan?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Bethenny is concerned about
how Alfonso
would deal with competition
for his hearts of palm
pasta business, Palmini.
How can you prevent the big guys
from doing this, though?
How can you prevent big
supermarkets just selling this?
Because I'm gonna get
one of your Sharks.
Well, you went
with the elephant.
Oh, that's the plan?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
When you run
with the elephants,
there's the quick
and there's the dead, right,
and if
you're quick enough,
you can stay
ahead of the elephant.
You can't own
how to chop a carrot.
You really can't.
You can do it ‐‐
No,
but there's different processes
that impact speed,
delivery.
Listen ‐‐
I love
how passionate you are.
This is
a huge, huge trend.
I think
that you should get into
this
alternative‐foods space.
I like
cauliflower‐crust pizza.
Someone should be making
carrot pasta.
I haven't seen
a whole line yet,
so you should be
the manufacturing guy.
But I don't see you
blowing the doors off with this,
because everybody can copy you,
so I'm out.
Yeah, I'm ‐‐ I'm...that's...
Sorry, you have no idea
how hard it is to make.
Like...
John: Okay, so maybe that's why
you value the company.
$300,000 for 10%
means that you're saying
the company
is worth $3 million.
But I don't think that Del Monte
or any of them
are going to even
blink their eye
when this gets hot and
they're just gonna do something
very similar
or even better.
I don't believe it's worth
that value, so I'm out.
Okay.
Alfonso,
let me tell you where I'm at.
I love pasta.
I don't eat as much of it
because of those bad guys ‐‐
calories,
trying to watch my weight ‐‐
but I don't believe in
a sliced‐up
vegetable substitute for pasta.
I don't see it.
I'm out.
Okay, I just want to say
one thing.
I am convinced
that this is gonna be
what Splenda is to sugar
or what Diet Coke is to Coke.
Like, eventually, because we're
just scratching the surface ‐‐
No way.
Greiner:
Wait a minute.
Hello.
Hi. [ Chuckles ]
All right.
I freaking love this.
Yes!
I think
this is awesome.
15 calories, 1.5 grams of fat,
and no sugar!
This is genius,
and I would like
to be your partner
in taking this everywhere.
And Mark loves it so much,
too...
So much.
Yes!
...that he said,
"You know what,
let's do it together."
A lot of work in this,
as you know.
Lot of work,
yes.
I mean,
got to fix the packaging.
Absolutely.
Can I say
one more thing?
Herjavec: No!
There's an offer coming!
No!
[ Laughs ]
Be quiet!
Oh, sorry, sorry.
There's an offer coming.
Yeah, sorry, sorry.
Okay, well, because you're
getting two fantastic Sharks,
$300,000...for 30%.
Whoa!
Run...like...
Alfonso,
did you see that?
There was all that love,
and then...
Well, but you understand
how much work...
You got to pay
to play.
Right.
Herjavec: Wow.
And let me
tell you something.
People always think
that there is, like,
an elevator
to the top, right?
There's no shortcuts
in business.
Everybody has to take
the stairs.
But if you have
the two of us,
that's an express elevator
to the top.
Can you do the $300,000
for 18%?
No.
18%?
Okay, let's do 20%.
Come on.
Wow,
you got to love that.
It's a really good product.
He loves his business.
I'm telling you, Mark.
I promise
it's gonna be worth it.
We're saying the same thing,
Alfonso. We obviously think so.
$300,000, 25%.
Oh!
You got a second.
You got to say yes
right now.
Wow.
♪♪
Let's do it.
Frankel: Wow! Yay!
Wow.
I love it.
Thank you,
Lori.
It's so good.
Oh, awesome.
[ Laughs ]
I'm so happy
you like it.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
It's really good, man.
Congrats.
It's so good.
Lori, now will you have us
over for dinner
and cook us
Palmini pasta?
Greiner: Yes.
Palmini for everybody!
I'm super excited.
It's a little bit more equity
than what I wanted to give,
but if it's Mark and Lori,
I would've done 30%.
[ Chuckles ]
Let's keep it between us.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a product
that aims to be a cure
for the dreaded hangover.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Brooks Powell.
I'm the founder of Thrive+,
and I'm here asking for $400,000
for 10% of my company.
Herjavec: Wow.
Wow.
Just three months ago...
Whoo!
...I graduated
from Princeton University...
♪♪
...and started full‐time work
on Thrive+,
the business I've been building
in between classes
since I was a sophomore.
Sharks, we use a number of
different products in our lives
to reduce the risks
and negative effects
of our everyday activities.
Anytime we enter
a motor vehicle...
we wear seat belts.
Whenever we spent time
in the sun...
we use sunscreen.
[ Chuckles ]
But you know what, Sharks?
The majority of Americans
also consume alcohol regularly.
[ Can opens ]
♪♪
Ah.
[ Laughs ]
Why don't we have a product
designed to reduce
alcohol's negative effects?
Well,
that's why I created Thrive+.
With the help of a Princeton
neuroscience professor,
a Princeton alumnus specializing
in chemical patent law,
and a pharmaceutical
manufacturer,
I invented the first product
ever designed
to reduce the negative effects
of alcohol.
It works primarily by reducing
short‐term alcohol withdrawal
and giving your liver
the enzymes it needs
to process alcohol
and other toxic byproducts.
To use Thrive+,
you just take three capsules
after your last alcoholic
beverage or before going to bed.
It's that simple.
Thrive+ is a healthier and
more responsible way to drink.
It'll even make you feel better
and sharper
the next morning
when you wake up.
So the only question I have
for you, Sharks,
is who wants to thrive with us?
[ Chuckles ]
So it's a hangover cure.
Do we get samples?
It's somewhere between
a hangover cure
and a multivitamin
for people who drink.
There you go.
Thank you.
Now, Mark, I know how much
you hate dietary supplements.
Thank you.
It is ‐‐
You do not like them.
Don't like
investing in them?
No, just depends
on the claims.
So hear me out,
'cause...
We'll be friends.
Well, we'll listen.
You have to be in college
to be able to read the back.
Herjavec: Wow.
That's small.
Right?
That's a big part of ‐‐
I don't see anything in here
that's unique.
So, what's unique
is the dihydromyrecetin.
Cuban: Before you get
too deep into that...
I want to hear it!
But I ‐‐ We'll hear it.
We don't see that
on here.
I have a rule.
The longer the backstory,
the more BS in the deal.
Okay.
Cuban: So just ‐‐
Can I just hear ‐‐
He can continue.
He has one unique thing
about his product.
Let him finish.
Okay.
Powell: Okay.
So, in Asian countries,
they would steep it as a tea
and it made them "feel better"
after consuming alcohol.
Neuroscientists wanted to see
if there's actually
any sort of scientific evidence
for this,
and what they found
when they injected
this dihydromyrecetin into rats,
they could instantly
sober up rats.
They could prevent rats
from becoming alcoholics...
But I want to understand
how many rats,
how long
was the study...
Wh‐‐ Are you serious?
Greiner: Seriously.
Oh, my God, Lori!
John:
Are you able to ‐‐
I'm gonna ‐‐
Wait, wait!
How old were the rats,
and how many cocktails ‐‐
I'm gonna tell you
why that's important.
Lori, you hang out with
a lot of rats at the bars?
Greiner:
I'm gonna tell you why.
What we want to know is
the quality of the study.
So, I want to know
how big is the study?
Cuban: We want to know
the quality of the study.
Yes. What's the quality
of the study? How big?
So, this was ‐‐
this was actually funded
by a $2.5 million
government research grant,
and the journal was
the Journal of Neuroscience...
Okay.
...which if you get published
in there,
that's the height
of your career.
This is why Big Pharma companies
didn't go after it...
Ugh.
...because it's
a naturally occurring
organic compound
that they can't get
intellectual property around.
But can ‐‐
can I do it?
Can I go make a product
using that?
Cuban:
Yes, of course.
So, I'm reading this
right as it's published.
I run to my Princeton
neuroscience professor.
He gets so excited about it.
I said, "Look, I really want
to bring this to the world,"
and I finally reached an alumnus
specializing in
chemical‐patent law.
And so basically,
what he said is
if you can combine it
with other ingredients,
then what you can do
is create a formula,
and then you can get
a novel patent
and now you have something that
can be better than competition.
How did you prove it?
Who are you
marketing this to?
Wait, how did you prove ‐‐
how did you prove
that your formula
was more effective
than the molecule itself?
We had
a small human study.
There's a problem
with dihydromyrecetin.
It has a bioavailability
of only 4%.
So what that means...
What does that mean?
...is you could take
1,000 milligrams
of dihydromyrecetin ‐‐
that's how much
is in a dose there ‐‐
and only 40 milligrams
are actually gonna get into your
bloodstream and do something.
Now, there's only a few labs
in the world.
One of the labs is at Princeton.
What they can make
is nanoparticles.
Nanoparticles can unlock
the bioavailability problem ‐‐
John: Are our ‐‐
You know what?
Are our phone calls gonna be
this long?
Let's get into the reality
of where you're going with this.
Tell me if I'm wrong,
that using the technology
that you licensed
from Princeton
is how you're gonna use
nanoparticles
to do a delivery of DHM
at a much higher
bioavailability level.
You nailed it.
I know.
This is
a very confusing presentation,
because
I'm kind of lost.
Listen, I'm not a genius
and I don't know about science
and I don't even know half of
what you guys are talking about.
That's the point.
I'd like to know who
you're marketing the product to,
who
the target audience is.
Yeah, but we've got to know
if the product ‐‐
it doesn't matter.
If the product isn't
legit, it doesn't matter.
John: Yeah, if someone
wants maybe out
for ethical reasons
or science.
It does matter,
because I don't even understand
by looking at the packaging
what it is,
who it's marketed to.
Is it marketed
to 20‐year‐olds?
We don't know if it's BS or not.
We got to find that out first.
Are we gonna dissect a rat, too?
But most supplements
are BS.
It's m‐‐
It's packaging.
Well, he's trying
to tell us otherwise.
He's got ingredients that are
the same in any other product.
Wait, how ‐‐
hold on, hold on, hold on.
So here's where the BS meters go
[Imitates beeping].
Saying "nanoparticles" sounds,
"Wow, this must be amazing."
Using na‐‐
I run
when I hear "nanoparticles."
I don't even know
what that means.
Yeah.
I run. I hear "nanoparticles,"
I run.
But ‐‐
It's new ‐‐
It's new technology.
When you try this product once,
you'd be like,
"I'm gonna rethink my"...
Cuban: But, Brooks,
that's not the point, right?
Using nanoparticles for delivery
is not something
that's exclusive to Princeton
or anybody.
There's a thousand
different companies
competing in that area.
They might have a certain way to
do it that they own the IP for,
but there's alternative ways
to do it.
Yes.
We're locking
all of those down.
But, Mark, listen ‐‐
This is my‐‐
I'm in the alcohol business.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
I would've been the person
to do this.
Good luck, I'm out.
♪♪
So, Brooks, you know what
just happened here today?
You had
a Cuban heist.
♪♪
You did
an awful job today
because you let Mark
take over your presentation,
and I never had a chance
to learn anything.
I'm out.
Okay.
I could not agree more,
and you did shush me.
Like, you went like this
three times,
which I feel
like I don't ‐‐
'Cause you tried
to interrupt me.
No, I did‐‐
Then just don't interrupt me
and it won't happen.
Everyone's talking. No, Mark,
you haven't stopped talking
for a good 45 minutes.
Hang on, Mark,
you don't have to push her.
Yeah,
'cause I want ‐‐
'Cause I got
to the root of the issue.
But everybody's getting a chance
here to learn something,
and I couldn't agree
with him more.
Every time I said,
"How much" ‐‐ "Eh!" The ‐‐ "Eh!"
Like, no, homey,
don't play that.
Don't interrupt me
and it's not an issue.
Mark, you can't
not interrupt you
because you haven't
stopped talking.
Well, 'cause I try
to ask the right questions.
But I want
to ask a question, too.
Herjavec: It's the right
question to you.
Ask. Instead of
talking to me, ask.
I'm supposed to ask ‐‐
Bethenny, let's hear it.
Hold on. I'd like to ask the don
and kiss the ring.
Feel free.
May I now speak?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I'd like ‐‐
Okay.
So, I'm in
the alcohol business.
I don't know
who this product is for.
The majority of our customers
are between
the age of 35 and 55, okay?
Okay.
This is basically
your customer base...
Okay.
...with your brand.
You buried the lede,
'cause that would've been
very important.
We can then go through
Mark's master's degree
in science after,
but you did
bury the lede.
The unfortunate thing
is that when that's on a shelf,
people
don't even understand ‐‐
We don't sell on a shelf.
We sell online.
Well, hopefully ‐‐
Okay, well,
that's you're whole...
Not for
two or three years.
We didn't know that was your
model that you only sell online,
so there's another piece
of beautiful information
we could've all known.
We not gonna go to retail
for two to three years
because you need TV ads
for that,
you need radio ads for that...
Oh, well,
then that ‐‐
...you need bigger ‐‐ far ‐‐
No,
I want a product
that you can understand
any which way but Sunday.
The marketing in this business
is very difficult.
I'm out.
Okay.
My biggest challenge
is something you said.
TV ads
and all this type of stuff ‐‐
it's a massive
amount of money
that you're gonna
have to spend.
I just think
it's a long journey.
I'm out.
♪♪
The problem for me here is,
it's just a little early.
You have
a lot of testing to do
before I would feel safe
in you marketing it
and it being able
to really take off.
So for those reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Herjavec:
Thank you, Brooks.
Thank you, guys.
John:
Thank you.
♪♪
Powell: It was like a bloodbath
in there.
I think a Shark could've sped up
our timeline of our company
by a year or two.
But that doesn't mean we can't
go on and be wildly successful.
I think 365 days from now,
they're gonna look at it and go,
"Man,
I could've made $10 million."
Do I get a credit
for that science class?
It's "Shark Tank."
Yeah.
You're supposed to pitch
a business.
Mark ‐‐
No, it's "Mark's Tank."
But you know ‐‐
No, no.
Do you think it's okay
for everybody who watches,
because we don't get into
the details, to get ripped off?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Because it's all about
the business and not ‐‐
Don't put words
in my mouth.
Okay,
then tell me.
The premise of our show
is you have a business.
There's a reason we do
due diligence after the fact.
But the people ‐‐
I have to give him
a certain amount of credibility.
Wrong, wrong,
wrong, wrong.
So you ‐‐ So you're so arrogant
that you believe, in an hour,
you can decide whether
the science behind it
is real or not?
I'm arrogant enough
to think
that I'm gonna ask
the questions.
My approach is, when I see ‐‐
when my antennas go up
and I think
there's a potential rip‐off,
I want to know
if it's a rip‐off.
I don't disagree with you,
but I also think
whoever's pitching here
needs to control the room.
Control the room.
Yeah,
but he's not ‐‐
You're presenting.
Then go yell
at him.
You got to control
the room.
Then you got to go
yell at him.
Bring him back ‐‐ Bring him back
out here. We'll yell at him.
♪♪